mucho de lo que trata la geometría es
demostrar cosas acerca del mundo y para
poder demostrar estas cosas del mundo
hay que ser muy cuidadosos precisos y
exactos con nuestro lenguaje de manera
que sepamos lo que describimos y lo que
suponemos y el tipo de deducciones que
hacemos conforme vamos haciendo las
demostraciones y para practicar la
precisión y exactitud con nuestro
lenguaje vamos a realizar algunos de los
ejercicios de la sección de ejercicios
de definiciones geométricas de khan
academy esta primera ejercicio dice tres
estudiantes intentan definir qué es un
segmento aquí está dibujado el segmento
puedes hacer coincidir los comentarios
del profesor con las definiciones aquí
tenemos las secciones definiciones y de
este lado están los comentarios del
profesor que podemos mover así que vamos
a pretender que somos el profesor veamos
la primera definición la definición de
ibi todos los puntos alineados con p
que se extienden infinitamente en ambas
direcciones bueno pues como que esto de
direcciones
no suena a la definición de un segmento
más bien suena a la definición de una
línea así que elegimos el comentario del
profesor que dice estás pensando en una
línea en vez de un segmento veamos la
siguiente definición la definición de y
tan la distancia exacta de p aquí pues
no no se trata solo la distancia cuando
hablamos de un segmento así que en la
respuesta que hay aquí hay más en un
segmento que es un longitud ese sería el
comentario del profesor la última
definición definición de ebook a los
puntos vehículos llamados segmentos son
todos los puntos en una línea recta
entre los puntos p y q está así es la
definición de segmento los puntos que se
encuentran entre el punto p y q y que
forman una línea recta así que es la
respuesta muy bien estás en lo correcto
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta
correcto veamos la siguiente pregunta
ahora nos dice tres estudiantes intentan
definir qué es un círculo puedes hacer
coincidir los comentarios del profesor
con las definiciones es lo mismo que
hicimos en el ejercicio anterior
veamos la definición de ruby una figura
tridimensional cuya frontera consta de
todos los puntos equidistantes a un
punto fijo en el centro bueno suena bien
pero aquí la cuestión es que estamos
hablando de algo tridimensional y esto
de que sea tridimensional pues son tres
dimensiones así que esto suena más a una
esfera estabas pensando en una esfera
ese sería el comentario del profesor
bueno la siguiente definición definición
de xira el conjunto de todos los puntos
en un plano 2d tal que para cada punto
en el conjunto hay exactamente otro
punto en el conjunto que está a una
distancia de de llama la diámetro
unidades
pues como que suena medio raro ya que
nos están hablando de un conjunto de
puntos que los llevan a otro conjunto de
puntos que está a una distancia de y
esto pues como que no suena tal cual a
un círculo voy a cambiar el comentario
esto es incorrecto por ejemplo tu
definición también permite la siguiente
figura que solo es parte de un círculo
vemos la definición de avisé que el
conjunto de todos los puntos en un plano
que están a la misma distancia radio de
un punto dado centro está si suena
correcta suena a una definición formal
de círculo vamos a comprobar nuestras
respuestas correcto vemos la siguiente
pregunta
ok tenemos el segmento ave y segmento
cede se interceptan en el punto o como
se muestra a continuación seleccione la
proposición más precisa y correcta de
las líneas perpendiculares de entre las
opciones dadas vamos a ver
tenemos el segmento ave este de aquí
dice que es perpendicular al segmento c
de este segmento si las dos líneas nunca
se encuentran pues no esto no es una
línea perpendicular porque estamos
viendo que de hecho se tocan en un punto
entonces esa no es la proposición más
precisa al contrario esta está
incorrecta veamos la siguiente el
segmento ave es perpendicular al
segmento cede si las dos enes se
intersectan de tal forma que el ángulo
que forman a o d sea un ángulo recto en
efecto esa sería la definición más
precisa porque las líneas
perpendiculares forman un ángulo recto
en el punto en el que se intersecta pero
todo más vamos a ver la tercera opción
invento ave es perpendicular a cede si
las dos líneas se intersectan de tal
forma que el ángulo
o de mira lo mismo que el ángulo b o c
esto no se cumple ya que puedo tener un
ángulo ao de que sea igual al ángulo b o
c pero que sean menores a 90 grados que
sean más pequeños o incluso más grandes
mi opción correcta es la de enmedio
vamos a comprobar la respuesta correcta
veamos el siguiente problema selecciona
la definición más correcta y precisa de
líneas paralelas de entre aquellas dadas
las opciones que nos dan dos líneas
distintas son paralelas y una se puede
rotar para quedar sobre la otra no pues
como que esto no tiene realmente ningún
sentido porque si tuvimos que rotar una
pues quiere decir que no era paralela
veamos la siguiente opción dos líneas
distintas son paralelas si están en el
mismo plano y nunca se intersectan entre
sí
este si suena a líneas paralelas la
parte de que nunca se intersectan entre
sí y además están en el mismo plano está
si me suena a la opción correcta la
última opción dos líneas distintas son
paralelas si apuntan en la misma
dirección pues como que tampoco tiene
mucho sentido ya que puedo tener
diferentes líneas con diferentes
posiciones que me apunten a la misma
dirección así que no está nuestra opción
correcta es la opción de en medio vamos
a comprobar nuestra respuesta y en
efecto es correcta